ville fortifiée construite au milieu du
xvième siècle par les espagnols
[Musique]
m
non
plus d'un tiers des habitants sont des
afro colombiens des descendants
d'esclaves
[Musique]
la vider son métissage est aujourd'hui
un visage le voici peint sur le mur
comme un symbole
ce visage c'est celui d'anna lusa
célèbre mannequin engagés pour défendre
la cause des femmes noires de carthagène
c'est un artiste irlandais qui a pas
analyse à son visage a depuis fait le
tour de la commune
il m'a représenté sur trois profils
la fraude et
les a dessinées femmes ont dû se battre
pour préserver leur espace et leur
territoire c'est cela qui les abeilles
les trois gardiens mais la lutte doit
continuer et ne plus jamais qu'une
réduisent en esclavage et le l'on prenne
notre indépendance
[Musique]
écoulée
[Applaudissements]
le quartier de get ses manies a été le
théâtre de la révolte contre les
colonisateurs espagnols
ses habitants ont marché jusqu'au palais
du gouvernement pour l'indépendance
ils ont fini par l'obtenir le 11
novembre 1811
l'esprit frondeur et contestataire est
encore en eux aujourd'hui il se devine
sur les murs et les façades
les peintures urbaines sont un moyen
d'expression elles ont fini par gagner
leurs lettres de noblesse
[Musique]
certaines de ses oeuvres sont reconnus
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
wae nas bonjour
je devins s'il vous plaît
pensez vous du changement de ce quartier
c'est beaucoup plus cher dès aujourd'hui
les choses sont différentes
j'ai plus de travail par exemple
quant à l abri mais désormais les
touristes viennent ici pour voir les
graphies tri on dit même que c'est le
meilleur quartier a visité de tous
partagent n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et
le voilà parti dans son rôle aurait
commencé
ici l'espace public comores en faire un
axe de création artistique et comme si
le quartier était un grand à beaublanc
ou comment cette fois là ou quoi et mme
blanc contenant l comment peindre sur
les murs le climat notre réalité
loquet pas à ça qu'il
analysa se bat pour entretenir la
mémoire de ses ancêtres esclaves
l'exploitation de leur force de travail
a permis à la ville de devenir au xvième
siècle un des plus grands ports de
l'empiré espagnol est le centre
économique ou tout la mer des caraïbes
les esclaves ont payé le prix fort ils
travaillaient jour et nuit dans les
champs de canne à sucre parqués dans des
hangars torturés parfois jusqu'à la mort
quand il ne travaillait pas assez vite
ou lorsqu'ils tentaient de s'enfuir
au fil des siècles la ville est devenue
le principal port négrier d'amérique des
centaines de milliers d'esclaves sont
arrivés ici par bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
l'architecturé est aujourd'hui un
héritage de cette période coloniale
cette page de l'histoire javier cas
ciani la connaît sur le bout des doigts
chaque recoin chaque ruelle en porte les
traces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
aulas salut mon mac taf comment allez
vous qu'est ce que c'est
dans ce marché du centre ville
aujourd'hui réputée pour ses confiseries
deux cent mille esclaves ont été vendus
vous saviez vous vendez des esclaves ici
à la ville étaient vendus ici
on m'a raconté cette histoire
heureusement qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit
que les desserts
les giscard travailler dans la culture
de canne à sucre mais pas seulement il
en avait aussi dans l'ingénierie la
construction à la recherche de pierres
précieuses il ne s'agissait pas c'est le
terrebonnien de la force de travail qui
met aussi différence avoir créé
ce mélange qui à ce projet aujourd'hui
d'entente et des afrodescendants trappe
[Applaudissements]
c'est délicieux merci beaucoup
carthagène et fier de posséder l'un des
systèmes les plus complets de
fortifications militaires d'amérique du
sud
sur la muraille de la lignée de son
protégé à l'intérieur il y a quatre
géants et en face la mer des caraïbes
des pierres ont été extraits son ami
ahmed entre les mains des et
stabilisateur pour construire la
muraille
[Applaudissements]
ne restez pas seul
et est envoyé dans les autres colonies
comme l'équateur le mexique c'est aussi
en amérique centrale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les afro caribéens subissent encore les
retombées de leur tragique histoire il
majorité vit dans les quartiers
périphériques et défavorisés de
carthagène là où un habitant sur trois
vit en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
enfin on
doit faire en sait
encore une fois
tu peux me faire un nouveau rythme
théophile où est né ici il a monté cette
école de danse africaine pour tenter de
redonner un projet d'avenir ayew
jeunesse déscolarisée
c'est comme une famille cette affaire ce
sont les femmes
cette école de danse est une belle
opportunité pour que les jeunes s'en
sortent dans la vie c'est qu'on puisse
peut-être un jour réaliser les rêves
et suivez vous les pieds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
valeria est né ici cela fait déjà douze
ans qu'elle fait partie de l'école elle
rêve de devenir danseuse professionnelle
avec un style bien à elle un mélange de
danses africaines et qui est en pole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je danse je dénonce la
prostitution infantile et les grosses
acquisitions et le petit
je ne sais rien du tout je danse
j'espère qu'il va réussir à nous sortir
dans cette réserve les frères
et grâce à son pilote mark renshaw
dans la vie et que cela que des
séminaires
les ménages dont le revenu par ici
si la force face à
ceux qui tournent
dans quelques heures valérien l'a
présentée pour la toute première fois sa
chorégraphie le centre culturel de
carthagène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment tu vas mon amour est patente
c'est
aujourd'hui c'est le bras joué à peine
mrc
avait pas dans la tête de vincent changé
[Applaudissements]
elle vit avec sa mère maria dans cette
modeste maison
le père de valeria ne vit pas avec elle
a rencontré le professeur théophile a
réintégré la tendance a changé ma vie et
m'a fait lille et lorient ont fait à eux
avaient attaqué collègues même au
collège à des meilleurs neurath
yassa carbone on passe la main aux
phillies
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous montrer le meilleur de
moi-même tous ok théophile on appris
c'est aussi l'occasion de sortir avec ma
maman et de se passer du bon temps
ensemble
et surtout dans cet état
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la famille va découvrir les beaux
quartiers de carthagène ou restaurants
musées et galeries se sont multipliés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j
aimer l'art et c'est la première fois
que je viens ici
l'humour qui est impossible avec en
prime comme c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
ça va tu te sens prête
on peut
[Applaudissements]
est-ce pour ce type d'événement c'est
très important pour la gagner hors
afrique et ses impressions j'en passe
permet d'affirmer notamment place en
retour la dépasse les 2 et 3 juin et les
par ce biais rassurer les salons une
très forte que la nouvelle ait été le
palais de langage
[Applaudissements]
sert à rien
selon marianne qui va nous présenter ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le public est composé d'acteurs du monde
culturel metteurs en scène chorégraphes
valérien espère être repéré ce soir par
l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
aurait gratuit ce qu'elle fait social ce
n'est pas que de la confiance et de la
reconstruction sociale que ça soit elle
a tellement d'impact et compagnie des
gens comme nous qui la voit danser des
repartir avec la plus jeune âge de la
danse en 16
matches au masters
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis tellement fière d'elle
c'est tellement mots quand elle se
produit la
boule je suis tellement fier de tout je
t'aime tellement moment
et amiens
[Applaudissements]
l'héritage africain est bien vivant à 60
km au pied des montagnes il existe une
ville où il est visible et palpable un
village d'irréductibles symbole de
résistance et de liberté niché au pied
des montagnes san basilio des palanquées
fondée au xviie siècle par des esclaves
en fuite
originaire de guinée-bissau du congo du
sénégal ou du nigeria ces pionniers ont
fondé le premier palanquée le premier
village fortifié de l'histoire latino
américaine
le temps semble s'être arrêté pendant
quatre siècles les palin perros ont vécu
coupé du monde une autarcie salvatrice
puisque leur culture africaine et leurs
traditions ont été préservés
[Musique]
parmi ces traditions la surprenante
pratique de la boxe anglaise
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes du village s'entraîne tous
les jours dans son regard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vas-y doucement pas de mouvement sans
réfléchir
pedro salina enea palanquée c'est un
entraîneur heureux car tout le monde ici
veut faire de la boxe
quand tu viens de palets ok tu dois être
forcément tu te bats en compétition on
disait
alors la politique tu veux être présent
je les autres voilà tout
[Applaudissements]
le village qui a eu trois champions
mondiaux de bois
et parmi eux le plus grand de tous les
temps ça fait 10 ans 2
il reste évident surtout
[Applaudissements]
quedal pandele anthony charentaise de
centre et non le boxeur de légende de la
colombie
originaire de palanca il a été le
premier colombien champion du monde de
boxe
un titre gagné 1972 et qu'il a défendues
21ème fois à palmarès exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis cette petite salle de boxe est
devenue une fabrique à champions les
boxeurs en herbe comme manuel torres se
prépare pour les championnats régionaux
ça y est démontré il
faut que l'on continue de montrer son
deuxième open qui évitera d intention de
poursuivre ce qu'ils peuvent aider à
[Applaudissements]
sauver tous être des champions
faire connaître son basilio des palettes
ou amont dans des avalanches
[Musique]
ont cessé de se battre pour conserver
leurs
autres activités ont refilé on est
aujourd'hui est 6e
[Musique]
leur combat pour la liberté a commencé
au début du xviie siècle à la tête de la
révolte domingo biolo un roi africain
réduits en esclavage par les colons
espagnols dans les champs de canne à
sucre ou le manque une armée de fugitifs
cette communauté marronne devient si
puissante que la monarchie espagnole
fini par lui accorder la liberté à
condition qu'elle cesse de s'agrandir et
qu'elle lui prête main forte en train de
deux mois
pedro l'entraîneur de boxe habite encore
dans la maison de ses arrière grands
parents
[Musique]
bienvenue chez moi
vous présente ma famille qu'est la
mayonnaise ici je le dis qu'avec des
femmes
[Musique]
c'est la petite cadette
comme toutes les femmes du village jana
et sa petite fille se tressent des
nattes c'est la coiffure des anciens
esclaves une coiffure qui renfermait
bien des secrets
[Musique]
la coiffure des femmes services de
cartes montrent le chemin de la ligue
n'a pas aux peuples de la région de
palin qui pendant le stage à saint
palais
car à la cheville elles tracer les
chemins qui indiquait parquet mais pas
ça est-ce qu'elle allait à éviter pour
signer sa
liste la plantation de la maison on
savait que dans les gardes ont fait une
presse pour indiquer que la maison était
là et que ça c'est le chemin
tu vois ces ondulations sert l'état sans
aviser les
aider
parce qu'il fait et il fallait bien
qu'ils se nourrissent les autres
esclaves qui cet été a donné à ces mêmes
bases et les mettent parfois parce que
c'est important pour nous de conserver
cela parce que mes l'assurance maladie à
l'aube à coller de préserver nos cadres
et ça se traduit aussi à travers nos
chapelles oif et
l'affronter
mme mcalpine tony stoll et la
globalisation et moss fête de la science
qui nous assure aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qui dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il paraît que tu veux te battre
contre moi
toiture a pas de quoi je veux monter sur
le ring
ici on parle très fort mais on n'est pas
du tout en train de s'embrouiller c'est
notre manière d'être et même être connus
en criant parfois mais ça ne finit
jamais en bagarre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette joie de vivre cette culture si
particulière attire aujourd'hui les
visiteurs du monde entier depuis 30 ans
chaque année au mois d'octobre a lieu le
festival de palenque
mode musique tambour échanges africain
pendant cinq jours les habitants de la
ville célèbre leur culture afro
colombiennes
[Musique]
des touristes viennent de tout le
continent pour y assister
ce groupe arrive du pérou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceci à palenque je suis très connu ça
avait dit combien gamin j'ai formé à la
boxe et qui sont ces mêmes aujourd'hui
dans un
nombre infime je parle de mon expérience
que personne n'arrive à lui touché la
tête comme en une minute moi je vais
essayer
je vais essayer de les toucher la tête
[Applaudissements]
je temporaire
ac j'ai gagné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réussi à en faire deux
[Rires]
il ya tellement de gens qui viennent
plus de 20 personnes tous les mois on a
beaucoup de choses à tout le monde et le
monde entier curieux de découvrir tout
ça manque en ça qu'elle a montré le
monde derrière monde intéressant
concerne notre réponse
[Musique]
le soir venu sand basilio dfa lankais se
métamorphosent la musique envahit des
touristes et habitants ce mélange sur
les rythmes afro cubains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez on y va il faut se dépêcher
dans cette école de danse les élèves
après mûri rythme africain après une
année de travail on s'apprête à
présenter leur spectacle
[Musique]
c'est très important car c'est la plus
grande manifestation culturelle de notre
village
et danse le loup balle ou un rythme qui
célèbre le passage de la vie à la mort
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais oh il vient le tambour est fabriqué
à
base est fait avec un tronc rentiers
tour en course comme ça fait ch
[Musique]
les a pas on utilise pour les danses
traditionnelles mais aussi pour le sait
rien moins qu'une erreur
dans cette danse qu'on parle de
l'histoire de catalina ce fait une jeune
femme symbole du symbio des fans qu elle
adorait danser
[Musique]
nous sommes vraiment dans l'afrique
colombienne l'école de danse enseigne
aux jeunes élèves les traditions
musicales du congo rapporté d'afrique de
l'ouest ont par les esclaves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir c'est la première fois que
reyssouze à jouer sur scène
ce soir j'espère que tout le monde va
pouvoir sentir l'homme du festival de
tambours de san basilio de palente et
precious et libye ouvre le festival
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]